yeah welcome to this video playing plug
August plague your wrist from from the
UK the funky line Bishop t6 and he's
answering with even strangers g5 amazing
yeah amazing that the kinds of moves
that I possible nowadays okay I'm
prevent g5 for the time being let's see
what is coming up now yeah Bishop d6
normally intense castles rook e8 Bishop
evade this kind of idea and the problem
is however going to Castle here probably
I've old castle hmm ok so a six you will
never take of course okay just retreat
it may be Bishop e3 any to somehow get
this the depot moving
so it seems he wants to Castle long
mm-hm if i take here take g4 it's got an
ID five ok this guy is just trying to
play player as weird as possible so yeah
it's probably not particularly good but
ok it's blitz can try all kinds of stuff
but objectively this is just a pawn down
all right the question is where to go I
could go to g6 em but no use I want to
play pawn to d6 and get my fish about so
just retreat the Queen maybe coin edge
force an idea now that I think of it
okay but it should be should be nice
anyway with what development just get
the pieces out yes okay so how to how to
develop him the ship f5 or bishop where
is 16 yeah maybe a five pro-reactive I
don't want to Castle shorty m27 long
castles so what I'm thinking of
yeah maybe you can cast a long play d4
something like that
I should have gone to a 2g for me ok but
I can I can still do that on before I
have any for now
hmm Jeff is maybe just trying to take
care Drake or take on g4 or something or
aged 30 maybe age three
okay so what now g5 therefore i can
cancel long I didn't really wanted to
give him the this is this Bishop but I
didn't really see how to how to prevent
it should I take maybe and then play
long castles I guess
hmm maybe he can yeah I can maybe use
the pin something like 92 and could be a
move didn't see that at all okay didn't
do that a positive thing is that he's
spending time not playing playing so
quickly yeah before be five
Queen f5 this an idea gaining this
temple hmm not sure
yes Jeff not to not show at all but
beehive I think I can take it's not not
a big issue we are adhere maybe a 5m a 5
on b5 night before why wait wait wait
night before this piece doesn't have a
square if you place the night hmm yeah
anyway I don't talk back here I mean I
don't get I don't retreat here the Sun
is not not on Queen f5 maybe it's an
additional an additional idea to have
this pressure on c2 oh ok I don't like
that and now just be 60 and cannot be
six to prevent pawn to be 60 g fo of
course as always this is trick that's in
the position I need to be cautious about
that
okay 95 Scott Bishop g4 oops no I wanted
to go here actually attacking deform
okay this wasn't too successful but it
didn't spoil anything time warning queen
bee three check check check check check
check check check check check check
check check check white forfeits on time
yeah he's just playing on time but I
managed with 40 41 hundreds of a second
at the end yeah wow yeah really
irritating they had much more time but
he went he got really quick at the end
the position of course is winning for a
phone for a while already yeah this this
opening is of course not not really
playable but it's always good enough to
to confuse them to confuse matters
but he didn't really have any
compensation for the pond not not sure
yeah I should have played maybe Bishop
g4 in the first place seems to be much
easier well yeah Kavita wants to just
take here but I don't understand yeah
this is good technically good and Queen
a five but I don't decide out the law of
g7 this is most not bad i mean i think
white um is still just a pawn down for
four not much here I thought you would
play the smooth this this at least gives
gives him a good diagonal I can play
here but still this is me yeah maybe a
better tribe this is just just winning
for black I guess yeah this added i
don't know i wasn't really it's see
three years the problem moving the night
and c3 but maybe he cannot manage I
didn't want to spend more time here ok
this is this is just just winning for
black only charges some time and I was
quick enough to not lose on time alright
thanks for watching